[Music]
in flat earther news submitted by Joe
Malian monk at each time religion a
self-taught rocket scientist plans to
launch himself into the sky to prove the
earth is flat
perfect self-taught scientist huh I love
that rocket howdy how's he gonna prove
that with a self-made rocket so he has
to go up himself without the assistance
of NASA and then take a look at the
earth you know he could probably do that
with those really high hot air balloons
so he so this man his name is mad Mike
Hughes that's not a great name for a
scientist the mad scientist job and so
he's planning to go up 1,800 feet above
the Mojave Desert and this homemade
rocket this was a terrible idea
traveling at speed of 500 miles per hour
so first of all if you guys don't know
this is what flat earthers believe our
earth looks like so they believe it how
do they know that I don't know they just
believe that's just a theory
yeah so they believe that the earth is a
disc and they believe that all of the
Earth's edge is icebergs or icebergs and
then so inside is where the Sun and the
moon circulate think of it as a disc or
is it is like a slight dome shape sounds
I also see north and south so I thought
it was like the edges are kind of a
little bit south of the center mm-hmm or
is it just song ourself so so so
everything is south
they don't believe in north west or east
I think I think they're trying to show
in relation what what our South looks
like to them hmm so what we think is at
arctica they think is just a ring of ice
yeah I think that's what they're trying
to say yeah and so like with heat when
mad mike is trying to prove his IP heat
well he's trying to go on convinced
until the atmos flat not atmosphere so
that most flat ooh
and so God knows and then see like the
entire Flat Earth and that he's gonna
prove that every astronaut every NASA
person just everyone in the world is
just lying about the fact that we live
live on this I have a question what the
[ __ ] is on the other side I don't know
what they like [ __ ] wouldn't it be
easier for him just to go all the way to
the end
well they're saying that it's like cuz
he a lot of the parts where there's
icebergs and stuff they don't let you
visit it it's like only if you're a
scientist or a researcher then you can
go to like Antarctica well you know how
they could prove it get a plane go to
Antarctica
and see if you could wrap around the
other side yeah how come he can't just
go into a plane and fly it himself and
just keep going
that's this Kedah I'll prove it if you
go straight in a straight line right due
south and if you continue going off into
the abyss then that's what happens it's
a flat but if you wrap a [ __ ] round
you're a [ __ ] poet you add up [ __ ]
in between rap a [ __ ] round yeah
homemade holy [ __ ] I am standing yeah
Photoshop her rocket ain't gonna get you
into space dude what the [ __ ] is that
that's a bobsled one with with a
firecracker into the Atmos I don't even
know what the hell that is well cuz they
don't believe in spheres that's not even
gonna be tall enough to take a picture
to show that it is flat though well good
for him pursue your passions bro yeah so
he was supposed to already launched his
rocket but he ended up postponing it
because he's started having mechanical
issues and also like legal issues cuz he
needs a permit of permits of some sort
we found that out later [ __ ] the permits
just do it homie prove the world
question is who's gonna pay for the
funeral that's a good question
you'll burn up in the end that's just
what you expect no fly that thing back
down to you or just gonna drop down
that's to be like a parachute or some
[ __ ] or some kind of yeah what if
they're right then look them in the
world goes flat yeah what if what if
they're right and they're like
see I told you guys that I'll be like
cool yeah we know now in my brain it's
flattened out awesome doesn't really
affect you I don't know guys I don't
understand the only reason I'm not the
only reason
aside from science what is the purpose
of telling everybody else that the
world's a sphere like what is the what
is the government's agenda to let us
believe that the real control is Damon
you don't even know they keep us
controlled because a circle is not a
square that's why but once you [ __ ]
find out that it's a flat surface oh man
chaos so they have to do this circle
[ __ ] I'm really curious as to what they
think is like under I haven't thought
that far how come when people fly they
go this around then they go back here I
know you mean they go back around and
they just fall off and die no well
there's that's what they're saying that
the whole earth is just like this also
there's going from destination the
destination this is the funny thing is
if you look at like flight routes and
stuff if that logic was correct then it
would take a very very long time for
this place to get to this place like it
doesn't make no sense wouldn't be
shorter
yeah that's or it was shorter or longer
so they like whatever the way that
they're flying right now it doesn't make
sense in this world yeah so they think
the Sun revolves around the earth that's
what I think what about the other
planets it's being believed that they
don't believe that the plans exist I
guess so do they think it's a half
circle no as like a dead eye like a
frisbee
why what's on the other side then of
that disk just roots of all the plants
sticking out yeah hold out [ __ ] a
tree there's just little dangly roots
like that this is why robots are gonna
take us over because like no matter how
much technology and education and things
we have there's always gonna be [ __ ]
morons yeah and that's all humans are
[ __ ] morons with technology yeah
playing mafia taught me that firstly
don't give a [ __ ] and how come all these
flat earthers always look like that
crazy
like I want like a flat earther to be
like Elon Musk you know what I mean
then there might be some validity to it
but there's these people who are all
self-taught scientists you know and
they're the ones that are these flat
earther believers so it looks like
somebody of like real like accreditation
says it then maybe I'll look into it
well it can't be cat because if you
think about it right like to have such a
radical thought you can't really like I
think just by Nature you already don't
look like the norm so you're already
gonna stick out like no but you must
Excel but he's a genius yeah every flat
earther I feel like has that you know
that janitor like key on the waist that
you could pull it out and there's a
[ __ ] chain that perhaps 500 keys I
feel like every flat earther has that
isn't a famous a lot of be Chris Paul I
believe he's a flat earther but they all
got those keys yeah yeah see none of
these people are of any form of like
high intellect yeah you see I'm saying
if Tila Tequila is on your side
they ain't she's not really helping your
little ass situation there anybody that
says they're a flat earther I
automatically assume you have IQ of
lower than 80 if you're a flat earther I
automatically assume you pee in your
sink because you don't want the
government to know that's the type of
person that you argue because I love
conspiracy theories and some of them I
believe in but a flat earther is just on
the other side of town yeah you're not
Neil deGrasse he's on Netflix and he
does the the space video yeah so he
ended up tweeting this recently
everyone loved it's this image of the
moon and like a disc and it says a lunar
eclipse flat earthers but have never
seen that moon looks like a gangster on
Instagram with a black bar across its
eye yes if our earth was flat this is
what the lunar eclipses would look like
but it's not but yeah this guy he ended
up going viral with his with his claim
that he's gonna be going up into the app
I want NASA I want what I want NASA to
do is to give him money that allow him
to create it so he could go up real ways
he's already almost trust me it's not
always that's good entertainment and
that's oh can you imagine the look on
the [ __ ] face after he goes up
and he realizes it's a sphere he comes
down and he's like [ __ ] dude you just
[ __ ] destroy this man's dreams and
we're killed we could all laugh yeah
it's gonna be it's like the best reality
show ever
yeah honestly I feel like this guy's
kind of faking it but he's a flat
earther because he previously launched a
rocket in 2014 he went up 1374 feet but
then the g-force is too much and then so
he ended up needing three days to
recover from that whole thing because I
didn't crashing down and I don't know
point even back then he wasn't a flat
earther and so now he became a flutter
from what I understand he became an
earther to get funding a lot of flat
earthers oh he's a troll Oh what is
underlying me he's always wanted to be
an astronaut but he could never do it
and so by going this way he can actually
achieve this because he was too stupid
huh I could kind of see that if you
could never be an astronaut from before
I should probably just stay away from it
yeah cuz if you can't have another
g-force you're just gonna die how old is
he ah looks like he's like 60 yeah I saw
the sixty years old if he goes up at he
explodes he lived a good life you could
probably look for another hobby not
perfect barbecue beans or something but
it's his [ __ ] rocket look like a
[ __ ] sale sign Mills kind of spin and
[ __ ] the guys they don't mention the
babes I kind of want to ride it they
look like the ones where you like put
like quarters in and then there's a look
a little rock no no like I wanna yeah
a cute look no is your mind everything
is cute but then this I wanna I want to
ride it like Shh
like this way not not up because this is
death this is if I we yeah that's a good
on him though I'm glad that you have a
hobby
and I'm glad that you probably don't
have friends too
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]